hey Gina we got an anonymous gift basket
yeah it's full of treats it's got meats
cheeses candies all the food groups
cheese is amazing it melts in my mouth
and in my hands huh
French chocolates French cheeses tiny
French pickles did none of you
detectives think this might be a gift
for captain holt from someone in France
like his husband Poe exalt what no way
this is a nice present from an unknown
appreciative citizen that wants too much
what's this then
dear captain Raymond holt thinking of
you best doctor kevin costner PhD he
even used their pet names
oh no I eat the chocolate-covered
strawberry that's the most intimate
snack of them all Holt's gonna be back
from his meeting in 30 minutes what do
we do no no no it's okay we can fix this
check it out sir a lovely gift basket
that Kevin sent you all the way from
Paris straight from Paris stapler
scissors rubber bands
that man really knows me yes uh I just
wanted to thank you for all your help
yesterday I didn't do much there was
nothing good day what's going on just
very busy get back to work what are you
having there a balloon large oh my god
captain she is magnificent
vindication I've been researching ways
to raise morale and I found an
interesting article in a scientific
journal Oh was it from the American
Journal of no one cares according to a
recent study the physical act of smiling
can improve your mood
I suggest we give it a shot hmm
now your try big smiles bigger bigger
great now we just have to stay like this
for the next few hours can you feel it
looking I don't have any enamel on my
teeth so the cold air is excruciating
maybe you brushed your teeth once in a
while this wouldn't be a problem
I do brush my teeth they're decaying
from acid reflux you're birthing
yourself for like a you're not
Australian Gina gets tough dude wrong go
okay so seriously too much exposure to
air and they will turn to dust this
isn't working out as well as I'd hoped
time for the next level forced laughing
wait for it wait for it
9:01 Amy Santiago is officially late for
the first time ever all right let's do
this who's got theories alarm didn't go
up all three alarms all with battery
backup come on who wants to take this
seriously
oh she was taken in her sleep that's
what I'm talking about
super dark Boyle the way more plausible
than the Sarge's idiotic alarm clock
theory I bet she tucked herself into bed
too tight and got stuck maybe she fell
into another dimension where she's
interesting it's 9:00 a.m. why is no one
working Amy Santiago is a few minutes
late and we're all trying to guess why I
like to play
I'd say she's in line at the bank this
is fun it is fun
but you're all wrong she clearly slipped
through a subway grate and is having
terrible sex with a mole man
there she is Amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself
I'm just 70 seconds late it's not a big
deal don't worry about it Santiago you
will tell us and you will tell us now
there's a problem at the bank
hot damn you're right what's that now
before I came to the nine-nine I was
rotting away behind a desk in the public
relations department all I wanted was
the chance to do good police work again
I just got it
and I blew it thinking about that Devil
toad
I'm tired of politics let's get that
punk blood so this is amazing of course
we have no idea where he is but I love
where your head's at death no family
maybe there was a girlfriend or someone
he worked with at the coffee shop at the
coffee shop why would someone who knows
they have 21 million dollars coming take
a minimum-wage job because he needed
access to that building because that's
where the money's hidden all right we
gotta get there quick maybe we should
take the chopper chopper death blade
Sidewinder
it's go time Roger that wet blanket snow
from now on call me valve it
alright here's where we stand this
nightclub is the home base for the
Merrick crime syndicate
I've been tracking the club owner
Vladimir Dragic aka the dragon aka
my first perp with a cool nickname what
about edible also dagger yeah it turns
out Rosa was lying about that el baboso
actually means the slug don't though
that means dum-dum it was very cruel I
referred to myself as el baboso to
several beautiful Latina ladies oh
that's your type isn't it jakey like
Sophia and son yeah yeah anyway the
dragon is involved in several counts of
human trafficking as well as I'm sorry
what's going on who are you
Chuck so with the organized crime unit I
mean for the mayor case materials oh are
you well we'll see what my captain has
to say about this thank you for taking
the materials make sure you also pick up
the files that on Peralta's desk wow
that is not how I saw it playing out sir
I thought you said this was my case I
gave you two weeks I'm done fending off
the organized crime unit squad since
Peralta's briefing was cut short you can
all use this time to clean up your desks
look at this place half-eaten food
crumpled tissues pictures of your
families what's wrong with pictures if
you love someone you'll remember what
they look like
what is this rubberband ball keep your
bands in a box or a bag since you all
apparently have time to play throw I'm
cancelling overtime for the month
effective immediately you have to work
and deep ball these bands ladies and
gentlemen we are gathered here today to
answer an age-old question right
what's Amy's deal she's single no we're
dating come on the question is who here
does the best impression of captain
Raymond Holt you'll be judged on voice
body language and overall lack of flair
everyone will perform the same scenario
captain Holt eating a marshmallow for
the very first time let the whole table
begin what is this glutinous monstrosity
before me sugar and this is quite sweet
that's your Holt impression I can hear
him doing that looks like a sticky
pillow I don't care for it classical
music
here what are you doing captain hey
nothing just eating some marshmallows
care for one marshmallow no sorry for
interrupting your dinner party no
problem at all this is important also
Kevin's friend Margo's here and she's a
real class a drip sir I can't get why
you don't want me to bother complain I
thought you of all people would support
me first of all let me say what that
officer did to you was wrong deeply
wrong and I'm furious about okay so why
don't you back me up because that
complaint could backfire cops who blow
the whistle on other cops almost always
face the backlash just like people who
socialize with Margo when Vera Blee here
about our trip to Scottsdale you've
really worked up about Margo sorry she's
horrible listen I don't want to see your
career derailed because you would
besmirched for reporting on another
officer but what he did was wrong he
should be besmirched yes but is that
besmirching worth a greater fortune of
your career you have to balance piss
merchants there's politics to be in a
cop but I wasn't harassed to be in a cop
I was harassed as a black man I'm not
saying do nothing I'm saying the most
powerful action you can take is the rise
through the ranks so that you can make
large-scale changes I've had to pick my
battles and it hasn't always been easy
but now I have my own precinct a
precinct whose officers would never do
to you what Officer Mike did I
understand what you're saying but I hear
Margo's quick issues not only one guess
as to where in Arizona she bought the
last oh great there you are I'm about to
start my scottsdale slideshow it has all
the highlights there are no highlights
in Scottsdale Margo that's what you
think Raymond which means someone took
cheddar and that person has the belt but
who talked cheddar where are you coming
from why do you care
thought you weren't hasting I'm not I'm
just interested in your comings and
goings because I care about you as a
friend okay friend I went to the
bathroom you were gone a long time
friend
you feeling okay Fran no it was number
two and it was very intense friend
bless you she sneezed dog allergies
which means that ami took where is my
dog aren't you standing right next to
him this [ __ ]
please watch Jake Jake idiot I know one
of you took cheddar and you did it for
the sake of the heist but if anything
happens to him I will end you I couldn't
bring myself to neuter cheddar but I
will neuter you
you